&gt;&gt; The first step here is to recognize that what we're looking for is the value
of x-coordinates where y equals 0 along this curve. So we need to set y equal to
0. Once we're here, we can come up with two separate equations that will help us
find values for x that will make this true. So we can either have 2x plus 1
equals 0, or we can have 3x minus 2 equals 0. If either one of these equals 0,
then this entire side of the equation will equal 0, and we'll be good to go. Now
we just need to solve for x. Solving for x gives us a value of x equals negative
1/2 for this equation and x equals 2/3 for this equation. If we plug either of
these in, we will make this equation true. But remember, I asked you for points.
And in particular, I asked you for what the x-intercepts of this equation are.
We can just read them off now, using these as our x-coordinates and remembering
that our y-coordinate has to be 0 for an x-intercept. Voila. Two lovely points.